modernity since it came about first in
Europe done by no dude in the whole
world has something standing features
but its characteristic on maternity
first and foremost it is distribution
through the market redistribution if
there is through the state and that's a
combination of capitalism and socialism
if I may say so
second it's a dissatisfied society
because the first slogan of modernity
was every person every man woman are
born free never before have the utter
descendants it was an absurd sentence
one was born immersed at the other was
born a slave the moment he said all men
are mostly we created a dissatisfied
societies because we are not free enough
because some are more free than us we
are not equally free so everyone is this
such as nothing wrong with
dissatisfaction this is what I want to
say because this after extraction keeps
our society alive and kicking
hello has just given a wonderful
demonstration of what it is to be alive
and kicking I felt I felt the table
vibrating under the effect of it I
actually wanted to say something else in
response to what Rory said which i think
is very important you referred to the
transfer of populations from small
villages to great megalopolis and how
this causes enormous disruption and
producing itself at a search for status
of a new kind i think i would like to
reflect on the fact that the great
cities that have grown in the modern
world have also brought along with
themselves an art and a literature of
loneliness you know a loneliness of a
new kind which you find in already in
Balzac but also in flow Barre and of
course paradigmatically in people like
Kafka and so on and the Central European
tradition and it's as though our need
for each other which is the thing that
is most beautiful in human beings
it's suddenly cut off from its from its
fulfillment at the very moment when when
it can be so easily fulfilled based in
so many ways and I think this is a most
interesting thing to reflect upon you
know that this is the major translate a
transition that we have that modernity
has imposed upon us this mass society
where we're surrounded at every point by
opportunities by people by opportunities
with friendship and and also opposition
and so on and at the same time there has
grown within that this unassailable core
core of loneliness